what happens to those from other religions
i believe this is what this was in reference
to the judgment what happens to those from
other religions what happens what happens
to them from other religions i suppose is that
she said there are some people who believe all
non-advertisers will be lost like some people
believe that why they believe that i don't know
now salvation and damnation is not based on
religious affiliations necessarily it is based
on your relationship to jesus christ of course
christ requires obedience don't misunderstand me
in in acts chapter 10 34 35 bible says then peter
opened his mouth and said of the truth i perceive
that god is no respecter of persons but in every
nation he that worketh righteousness fear with
god and worketh righteousness is accepted with him
now the greek word the nation is ethnic or ethnos
i think it is which gives us the word ethnicity
so in every ethnicity then we extend it to every
religious group there are those who have a heart
for god and when god calls they'll come now those
who live before the holy place the most holy
place was opened and the light of the lord shone
out they live before that they will also be saved
that includes martin luther those reformers asked
to roma i believe elohim mentions them they'll
be saved since the most holy place was opened
in 1844 october 22 the light of the sabbath went
out and people had to make decisions but wherever
there's genuine ignorance but a heart to serve god
based on all the person knows there is salvation
you see because god doesn't judge you based on how
much you know he judged you based on your response
to what you know if you know this he expects
that if you know this he expects that from you
and so it is not who is in another denomination
it is what is the person's relationship to christ
this is number one now surely we know from uh john
chapter 10 verse 16 other sheep i have which are
not of this fold them also i will bring and they
will i must bring they will hear my voice there
shall be one for one shepherd we know that we know
the loud cry of revelation 81 to 4 targets the
invisible remnant in the other churches that's why
the cry has come out of her my people we know that
but it's also true there are many people of other
denominations who have died not having received
certain specialized biblical knowledge but they
loved god to the extent of the knowledge they had
and they'll be safe when jesus comes but christ
has a remnant on the earth he really does he
has a remnant on the earth cornelius had a
heart for god he did not know the true god
jesus said peter there are people in that
condition and so i don't want to stress other
religions i wanted to stress what is your
attitude your relationship to jesus christ
i saw what will happen to you i'm not sure if
it's you no muslim i have another program right
after you another question i answered for the
church in jamaica the question may have come
from them i think it is what happens to 12 year
olds i believe it is one of their questions not
you so we'll skip that for now all right amen okay
and i accidentally skipped this question this is
from ingrid l she sees believers say i want to be
in that number which number is being referred the
144 000 or the great multitude which no man could
number as found in revelation 7. either one either
one you're safe now there's some people have heard
they'd love to be among the 144 000 that are alive
on the earth when jesus comes that number that
goes through the time of trouble such as the world
has never seen now i'm not sure people understand
what they're asking for when they ask for that
because the time will trouble will be terrible god
will put a lot of his people to sleep because they
cannot handle it so it sounds lovely to say i want
to be among the 144 thousands but remember when
jesus was in gethsemane he asked the father get
me out of this and in a certain sense the 144 000
will be going through that jacob's time of trouble
a suffering that requires a special brand of faith
and so whether it's a great multitude 144 000
wherever you locate yourselves you're safe
but try close to jesus you see that's the point
get close to christ one day at a time these
future projections i want to be in 144 000 in the
year 2026 no get close to christ now and he will
determine whether he allows you to go through or
he puts you in the grave to see but that's his